Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent le monde.
Nous allons vous parler
de l'éventail du sexe.
Comme les reste
des comportements humains,
les pratiques sexuelles évoluent
de l'hétérosexualité
à l'homosexualité et au-delà
avec la cybersexualité, les sextoys,
les sites de rencontres
jusqu'aux approches genrées,
transgenrées,
voire une sexualité transparente,
dite neutre.
L'éventail du sexe se décline
sur le mode
des plaisirs, des jouissances,
des fluctuations identitaires
et de la consommation illimitée.
Avec aussi des dérives violentes,
dont les viols de femmes constituent
la face noire
de la sexualité mortifère.
Depuis que le mouvement MeToo
a émergé mais pas que,
la parole des femmes s'est libérée
pour dénoncer
les violences sexuelles
en même temps que le désir féminin
s'est mieux affirmé,
libéré d'une tutelle patriarcale
qualifiée parfois de masculinité
toxique, voire machiste.
Avec quelles répercussions
sur la sexualité
des jeunes générations
et la sexualité
des seniors ?
La sexualité est aussi
un marqueur de civilisations.
Qu'il s'agisse de la répression
contre les femmes non voilées
en Iran,
de l'excision toujours pratiquée
dans les contrées africaines,
des entraves à l'avortement
dans certains Etats américains,
la liberté sexuelle s'apparente
politiquement au libre-arbitre
laissé à chacune et chacun
de jouir de son corps
comme bon lui semble.
Jusqu'où est-ce possible ?
C'est ce que nous allons voir
dans cet éventail du sexe
avec Magali Croset-Calisto,
vous êtes sexologue,
psychologue, essayiste.
Marc Strauss,
vous êtes psychiatre
et psychanalyste.
Corinne Fortier,
vous êtes anthropologue
au Collège de France.
Philippe Brenot, vous êtes
psychiatre, anthropologue
et directeur d'études
à l'Université de Paris.
Alors, commençons
avec notre grand poète Artaud.
Il sépare la sexualité de l'amour.
Dans le quotidien
des choses de la vie,
on a tendance à les confondre.
Qui a raison et qu'en est-il
en pratique ?
Philippe Brenot.
-Question qui mériterait
un très long débat,
entre sexualité et amour.
Moi, je dirais qu'à la fois, l'amour
est la grande affaire des humains.
Ca n'existe pas de cette manière
dans l'animalité.
Et d'une certaine façon,
c'est l'anthropologue
qui voit ce qui fait,
c'est tout ce que je recherche
depuis que je m'occupe
de sexualité :
qu'est-ce qui est humain
dans la sexualité ?
Il y a ce lien d'attachement
de l'amour,
toutes les sociétés
vont le décliner,
et la sexualité qui, en général,
dans toutes les sociétés
de la tradition, jusqu'à chez nous,
une soixante-dizaine d'années,
elle est fortement liée
avec la fécondité.
Nous vivons une période
je vais presque dire anormale
dans une partie,
la partie occidentale,
de l'humanité, c'est moins de 20 %,
dans laquelle
nous avons séparé l'amour,
jouissance quelquefois,
on va dire "on fait l'amour",
et puis la fécondité.
On peut très bien
avoir une sexualité
sans se reproduire,
on peut être beaucoup plus libre.
Donc, très difficile de...
Je dirais,
l'amour est certainement
l'un des éléments,
pour moi,
fondamentaux de m'humanité.
La sexualité est un outil
qui peut nous aider
à nous épanouir,
mais qui sert beaucoup
à la fécondité,
et le gros problème, c'est les modes
de pression qu'il va y avoir,
notamment dans les sociétés
de la tradition aujourd'hui,
avec toujours ce lien
sexualité-fécondité
parce que, dernier mot,
la plus grande invention,
pour moi,
de l'histoire de l'humanité,
c'est tout de même
lorsqu'on a pu séparer cela
et qu'apparaît en Occident
l'existence sociale des femmes,
parce que l'on peut
libérer les femmes
d'une contrainte
de la grossesse, de l'enfantement,
du soin permanent
et, d'une certaine façon,
de l'éviction de l'univers
et de l'espace social.
-L'anthropologue que vous êtes,
Corinne Fortier,
adhère à ce qui vient d'être dit ?
-Je vais parler en mon nom,
sans me référer
à ce qui a été dit avant.
Déjà, l'amour, ça peut exister...
Il y a l'amour maternel,
par exemple,
qui est justement, où il y a
des prohibitions de l'inceste,
et donc, pas de sexualité,
en tout cas permise.
Donc, il y a
quelque chose... Quand on pense
à ces amours qui ne sont pas reliées
à un partenaire sexuel,
on peut avoir déjà des amours
qui sont sans sexualité,
et même où la sexualité
est prohibée.
Donc, c'est un sentiment affectif
où il n'y a pas nécessairement
de rapport sexuel
qui lui est corrélatif.
Mais en effet,
les sociétés visant
à la reproduction,
à la reproduction d'elle-même,
de la société qui passe
par une reproduction physique,
il y a la nécessité
d'avoir une sexualité
procréative et qui est reliée
à un amour conjugal.
Or, le sentiment amoureux
peut aussi se développer en dehors
de la conjugalité.
Mais toutes les sociétés visent
à idéaliser l'amour conjugal
pour qu'il y ait,
à l'intérieur
de ce couple,
qui est légitime, une sexualité
reproductive, essentiellement.
Donc, bien sûr que les deux
sont liées socialement.
Je dirais aussi
que dans nos sociétés et ailleurs,
il y a une approche genrée,
où souvent,
les femmes pensent plus
que la question de la sexualité,
qu'il faut être amoureux
pour avoir des rapports sexuels,
ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
du côté des hommes.
-Pour vous,
Magali Croset-Calisto,
sur le lien amour et sexualité ?
-Je partage tout à fait
ce que vous venez de dire.
On voit que le sexe
est un outil,
et la vidée, le but du chemin
est encore l'amour.
Et dans toutes les grandes enquêtes
qui ont été faites
ces dernières années,
et Philippe Brenot
en a parlé longuement
dans ses livres aussi,
on voit que cette image,
ce mythe
du prince charmant
perdure dans notre société,
et de la bonne épouse.
Donc, les stéréotypes
fondent la résistance,
on est encore
dans des clichés bien ancrés
et normés, sauf que
les jeunes générations,
notamment Y et Z,
sont en train de nous questionner
sur ces schémas,
sur ces scripts sexuels,
parce qu'on voit que la sexualité
n'est pas vécue de la même manière
actuellement
par les jeunes générations,
notamment par ce que vous avez
appelé la sexualité neutre,
on peut parler aussi
de l'asexualité,
en un seul mot,
qui arrive de plus en plus sur
le devant de la scène aujourd'hui.
-Très bien.
Marc Strauss, quand même,
dans la citation d'Artaud,
il y avait quand même
une dimension plus universelle.
Il dit que ce qui sépare,
c'est la sexualité
et ce qui unit, c'est l'amour.
Qu'en pensez-vous ?
-Moi, je souscris
et je suis d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit aussi.
Mais la sexualité est un carrefour,
est une construction,
en fait.
C'est ce que nous a appris Freud.
C'est une construction qui,
d'une part, effectivement,
relève de l'aspiration,
à l'un, dans l'amour
et, d'autre part,
est l'expression
de la pulsion.
Et entre les deux,
ça coince toujours,
ça ne marche jamais.
C'est ce qui fait la difficulté
de la sexualité
pour tout le monde,
avec tous les symptômes sexuels
et l'intérêt
que nous portons à la sexualité.
Là, c'est un domaine
où nous sommes sûrs
qu'on n'en aura jamais dit
le dernier mot. C'est sans fin.
-Vous voulez dire
que l'amour est
un sentiment universel
et la sexualité
un bricolage technique ?
Rires
-Montage pulsionnel,
bricolage technique, absolument.
Absolument. C'est la position
de Freud, très explicite.
-Et la vôtre.
-Oui.
-Et c'est... Oui, Magali ?
-Ca renvoie à cette citation
de Freud,
on voit bien en cabinet
de consultation
les hommes qui viennent consulter
parce qu'ils n'éprouvent plus
de désir pour leur compagne
ou leur épouse, et Freud disait :
"Quand ils aiment, ils ne désirent
pas et quand ils désirent,
"ils n'aiment pas."
Il mettait déjà en miroir
sexualité et amour,
en questionnant l'articulation.
-Pour les hommes,
les confondre est difficile.
Plus que pour les femmes.
-Essayons d'aller plus loin.
Au moins
pour les sociétés démocratiques,
ce que nous sommes,
la législation dans le domaine
de la sexualité
avance au rythme de l'évolution
des opinions publiques.
Tout ou presque, si on exclut
les violences sexuelles et le viol,
est aujourd'hui permis.
Que pensez-vous
de cette émancipation
sans limites de la sexualité ?
Magali Croset-Calisto.
-Je ne dirais pas que
tout est absolument permis
dans notre société aujourd'hui...
-J'ai dit tout, sauf le viol
et la violence sexuelle.
-Oui, mais pas mal de femmes
disent encore
que si elles vivent
une sexualité libre,
il y a ce regard social
qui apparaît et qui les stigmatise
comme des femmes dévergondées
et je vous passe d'autres termes.
Donc, c'est encore pas si simple
que ça d'avoir une sexualité
égalitaire dans les comportements
entre les hommes et les femmes
dans notre société.
Par contre, ce qu'on voit,
j'ai eu l'occasion
de faire une petite étude
à travers le cinéma
des évolutions de l'orgasme
du début du 20e siècle
jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
on voit qu'il y a eu
au fur et à mesure des années
une sexualité
tout d'abord métaphorisée.
Exemple, le film de Renoir,
"Une partie de campagne",
tiré de Maupassant qui,
au moment de l'orgasme,
présentait l'animal,
le rossignol,
comme la métaphore de l'orgasme.
On retrouve ça dans d'autres films.
"Les amants", Louis Malle,
les mains s'attachent, s'enlacent,
c'est une scène formidable
où on voit le premier orgasme
d'une femme au cinéma.
Les années 70,
c'est l'orgasme érotique,
puis pornographique.
Avec les années 80-90,
on voit un orgasme
prophylactique
et presque violenté,
avec l'arrivée,
notamment, du sida.
Et ce qu'on aperçoit
depuis quelques années,
ce sont des orgasmes
de plus en plus numérisés.
-Pour parler de la sexualité
comme une évolution d'orgasmes,
c'est peut-être pas que ça,
mais pour vous,
comment vous définissez l'orgasme,
simplement ?
-Il faut voir
l'histoire de l'orgasme
pour comprendre comment fonctionne
une société.
-Mais votre définition
de l'orgasme ?
-C'est fabuleux parce qu'il y a
un grand paradoxe :
c'est une mise en tension
qui demande aussi un lâcher prise.
C'est appuyer en même temps
sur le frein et l'accélérateur
pour trouver le bon régime
qui mène au transport.
-Mais concrètement ?
-Le Trésor de la langue française
dit que c'est un état de gonflement
organique,
des parties génitales...
-De l'homme
et de la femme ?
-Oui.
Et ça se joue aussi, en parallèle,
au niveau cérébral,
avec une activation
du système nerveux,
notamment du circuit de récompense.
-Philippe Brenot, est-ce que
vous adhérez à cette histoire
de la sexualité qui serait
une succession d'orgasmes ?
-C'est pas tout à fait cela
que vient de dire Magali.
Je reprendrais quelque chose
que je trouve vraiment intéressant
pour comprendre l'idée première
de l'orgasme.
Dans son étymologie grecque,
"orgasme", c'est l'état du fruit mûr
qui va éclater.
On le voit très bien...
-Y a un jus qui sort.
-Si vous voulez !
Mais ce que j'allais dire,
c'est que lorsqu'elle évoque cela,
et en prenant l'image, par exemple,
de l'évolution dans le cinéma,
c'est très vrai
que la grande libération des idées
en matière de sexualité
depuis 70 ans à peu près,
les années 70,
on a vu venir
au devant de la scène
la jouissance,
et puis,
en grande partie maintenant,
les orgasmes,
parce qu'il a été,
j'allais dire interdit aux femmes,
je vais y venir dans un instant.
L'évolution que j'aurais vue
dans ces 70 années,
à peu près, j'aime bien la dire
de cette manière
en parlant de la France,
parce que c'est pas vrai
de tout l'Occident :
on est un pays assez libre
dans les idées
et je trouvais qu'on est venus
à une sorte d'absence
de jugement moral,
je ne parle pas
des 10 dernières années,
mais c'est vrai que,
même dans les années 50,
je crois qu'on devait signaler
des comportements qui,
sexuellement,
paraissaient inacceptables.
Aujourd'hui, on est arrivés
à quelque chose
qui était très libre,
à l'exclusion d'un seul interdit,
l'intrusion de la sexualité
des adultes dans celle des enfants.
Je le résume de cette façon-là.
Par contre, il y a quelque chose
de très nouveau qui se passe
depuis 20 ans,
en grande partie parce que
la sexualité féminine a été
beaucoup plus libérée.
En 1997, lorsque j'écris
mon "Eloge de la masturbation",
destiné aux femmes,
il a été reçu surtout
par les hommes,
le mot "masturbation" n'existait pas
pour les femmes à l'époque.
Qu'est-ce que l'on voit ?
C'est la libération
de la jouissance féminine,
la redécouverte
du clitoris, ainsi de suite,
mais là, les nouvelles générations
nous amènent quelque chose d'autre,
à nous qui avons connu
ces évolutions différentes.
On voit de quelle façon,
par exemple, nous,
en tant que psychiatres,
dans la première année,
j'ai été impressionné
par le nombre de témoignages,
on n'y avait pas été préparés,
de femmes, essentiellement,
qui parlaient d'inceste.
Le hashtag MeToo,
hashtag inceste ont fait,
même s'il y a des excès,
tant pis, c'est pas ça le problème,
ont fait plus en 5 ans aujourd'hui
que nos tentatives depuis 30 ans
d'essayer d'en parler.
On nous disait : "Ca existe
"dans certains milieux."
Bien sûr que non.
Donc, on a une grande libération
qui s'est faite,
quelque chose dans les jeunes
générations, tant mieux,
qui fait bouger les choses
avec, peut-être, attention,
parce que je disais libération,
absence de jugement moral,
c'est vrai qu'actuellement,
il peut arriver un retour
au jugement moral.
-Qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de cette évolution
de la sexualité, Marc Strauss ?
Elle est libération,
elle est consommation,
elle est expression de la jouissance
tous azimuts ?
-Elle se dit libération,
et pourquoi pas.
Mais j'ajoute là aussi, si
vous permettez,
à ce que vous venez de dire
la sexualité infantile.
La sexualité infantile,
elle est traumatique,
elle est angoissante,
elle est sans issue.
Il y a d'une part
la curiosité brûlante
des enfants
sur comment on fait les enfants,
la différence entre un garçon
et une fille,
et il y a aussi
l'excitation sexuelle.
Une excitation sexuelle
qui est déclenchée par des incidents
absolument contingents,
qui ne sont pas
nécessairement sexuels,
au sens génitaux.
Et comme ça
s'impriment un certain nombre
d'images fixes
qui vont déterminer
les choix adultes.
Et cette sexualité infantile,
elle est et elle restera
honteuse et coupable,
toujours. Et donc,
excusez-moi, on peut dire :
"Masturbez-vous, masturbez-vous",
quand j'étais jeune, on cachait ça,
la masturbation se faisait
en cachette, honteusement.
Maintenant, c'est admis,
tout le monde le fait.
Mais ce qui a, à mon avis, remplacé
la chose, c'est la pornographie.
Tout le monde le fait aussi
mais on ne s'en vante pas encore.
-Très bien.
Comment vous voyez ces évolutions
de la sexualité ?
-J'ai pas l'impression
qu'il y ait de réelle évolution.
Toutes les pratiques sexuelles
ont toujours existé,
sauf qu'on en parlait moins,
c'était plus tabou.
Là, c'est rendu public
par une société
qui est avide, aussi,
de témoignages,
de vidéos pornographiques,
mais toutes
ces pratiques sexuelles,
on n'a rien inventé aujourd'hui,
que ça soit la sexualité
ou bien tout ce qui peut exister.
Mais en fait, moi, aussi,
je suis assez mitigée,
parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a justement derrière
une grande injonction,
en particulier
à travers la pornographie,
pour les femmes et en particulier
pour les jeunes filles,
qui pensent que si on n'a pas fait
un certain nombre
de pratiques sexuelles,
on ne va pas faire plaisir
à l'homme, on ne va pas être
reconnue comme une femme.
Il y a aussi un rapport,
je pense à l'adolescence,
entre sexualité et identité
qui est très fort.
-Vous voulez dire qu'il y a
un prosélytisme, en quelque sorte,
de ces pratiques-là ?
-Oui. Il y avait la chanson
de Brassens qui faisait l'éloge
de la jeune fille
qui reste pucelle.
Aujourd'hui,
si à un certain âge,
on n'est pas entré
dans la sexualité,
on n'est pas considéré par ses pairs
comme dans le coup.
On est arriéré,
on reste encore enfantin,
on n'est pas complètement adulte.
Je pense qu'il ne doit pas
y avoir d'injonction...
-Vous pensez que la société,
aujourd'hui,
pousse à ce que les gens consomment
un peu tous les modes sexuels ?
-Exactement.
Et surtout pour les filles,
où je pense aussi qu'il y a
une certaine forme d'effraction,
pour reprendre le terme
psychanalytique.
C'est pas la même chose
que pour un homme,
enfin, ça dépend
des pratiques sexuelles,
et donc, il y a un certain...
Tout d'un coup, parfois,
elles doivent faire
énormément de choses
alors qu'elles n'entrent pas
dans une pratique
où elles vont connaître leur corps
et des pratiques
sexuelles progressivement.
Ca peut être
assez traumatisant, et il y a
une réelle injonction à ça.
On voit même que mai 68 était
considéré comme une libération,
mais derrière,
il y avait encore
un patriarcat, une demande
des hommes, qui jouissaient
de ces corps féminins
qui étaient plus libres,
mais où les femmes elles-mêmes
n'avaient pas
toujours de liberté.
-A ce niveau de la discussion,
est-ce qu'on peut parler
distinctement
d'une sexualité féminine
et d'une sexualité masculine
ou est-ce qu'en fait,
c'est des conduites indistinctes ?
Qu'en pensez-vous ?
-Et vous me regardez
et c'est difficile.
-Si vous voulez pas,
je laisse Magali répondre.
-Je suis d'accord avec
ce que vous venez de dire,
il n'y a rien de nouveau
sous le soleil.
On n'a pas inventé,
sauf des choses très particulières,
par exemple dans le monde gay,
il y a des pratiques
très spéciales,
mais la sexualité
des couples est tout simplement
certainement plus libre
que celle
de nos arrière-grands-parents.
Il n'y a pas la promiscuité
ou la gêne,
et tant mieux, pour cela.
Par contre...
Il y a deux mouvements.
C'est vrai que le mouvement
des études sur le genre
amènerait l'idée
qu'il n'y a pas de distinction.
Qu'il ne doive pas y en avoir,
je suis d'accord, c'est-à-dire,
qu'il y ait autant
d'égalité, de parité,
entre garçons et filles.
Il y a des différences.
Il y a de fortes différences,
notamment,
c'est vrai
que la sexualité masculine,
qui semble pulsionnelle...
Moi, j'aimais bien
une phrase de Luce Irigaray,
une grande féministe
des années 70,
qui dit : "La femme
a des sexes un peu partout,
"elle peut jouir
d'un peu partout."
Et c'est très vrai.
Je mettrais en parallèle...
Ca, c'est de moi,
pour faire un parallèle.
L'homme n'a un sexe presque
qu'au niveau génital,
je caricature pas,
c'est là que nous avons
le plus de sensations,
et il ne sait pas trop
jouir autrement.
Le jeu, quand même,
si on parle d'hétérosexualité,
serait que chacun apprenne
que le registre de l'autre
est assez différent et là,
un homme s'ouvrira
à une sexualité autre.
Quand on reste dans ce type
de stéréotypes,
qui sont millénaires,
ça amène des échecs.
-Oui. Magali,
sur cette différence
entre les deux ?
-Je suis les propos
de Philippe Brenot,
parce que je pense qu'il y a
un orgasme global.
Freud parlait de pansexualité,
à l'époque,
en disant que le corps
était rempli
de zones érogènes,
donc potentiellement
excitables,
de diverses parties du corps.
Chez les femmes,
on a tout de suite vu
qu'il y avait un clivage
entre l'orgasme dit "vaginal",
je dis "dit vaginal",
parce qu'il a été déconstruit,
et l'orgasme clitoridien.
Or, les femmes, on le sait,
peuvent jouir
de plusieurs endroits du corps,
des seins, notamment,
des tétons, etc.
L'homme, lui, on a parlé
d'orgasme pénien, effectivement,
car c'est l'endroit du corps
le plus innervé.
Il jouit principalement
de ses parties génitales,
mais il peut aussi jouir
d'autres parties du corps.
La communauté homosexuelle
le dit depuis longtemps.
Aujourd'hui,
les créateurs d'accessoires,
de sextoys,
le savent très bien,
car ils vendent énormément
de sextoys intimes masculins
qui concernent le point prostatique.
La prostate, chez l'homme,
est un des endroits qui peut
apporter un plaisir diffus,
donc ça chamboule,
ça bouleverse toute la construction
imaginaire de l'orgasme masculin,
parce que du coup,
l'homme peut devenir polyorgasmique.
-Je vous ai entendue.
Marc Strauss, vous avez écouté
ce qui a été dit,
des orgasmes
sur différentes parties du corps,
le corps
excitable à différents niveaux,
pour l'homme, la femme.
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
une banalisation
du rapport sexuel
tel qu'on le concevait classiquement
et quelles conséquences
cela peut avoir, à votre avis ?
-Si vous permettez, là aussi,
un petit rappel de Freud,
à la fin de l'article
sur la genèse
homosexuelle,
c'est très frappant de voir
l'extraordinaire distance,
l'absence de jugement moral de Freud
sur l'homosexualité.
Il considère que l'homosexualité
n'est pas un problème
pour la psychanalyse.
Elle doit rendre compte
du mode du choix d'objet,
mais n'a pas à en juger.
Il explique
qu'il y a les traits physiques,
sexuels, homme, femme,
anatomiques,
les traits psychiques,
et les modes du choix d'objet.
Les trois peuvent se combiner.
Les positions psychiques
peuvent être masculines
ou féminines, chez un homme
et chez une femme,
au sens organique,
et l'objet peut être
homme ou femme.
Ca fait pour chacun
quatre positions possibles, déjà.
Et donc, Freud laisse entendre
qu'il a une position
féminine distincte.
Ensuite, il élude en disant :
"Ca a quelque chose à voir
"avec la passivité,
et l'homme, l'activité."
Lacan le reprend et le formule,
vraiment, le théorise,
comme l'accès
pour tous les parlants,
tous les êtres humains,
l'accès possible
à une jouissance autre.
Il y a la jouissance, effectivement,
physique, pénienne,
clitoridienne, la jouissance,
disons, apaisante,
celle qui détend, qui décontracte,
la masturbation,
ou de la pénétration
du coït,
et il y a quand même,
plus facilement accessible
pour les femmes,
une jouissance autre qui a
à voir, effectivement,
avec l'amour,
avec la spiritualité.
Et c'est un développement
de la position assurée
de Freud de la bisexualité
constitutionnelle
de l'être humain.
-Et vous, Corinne Fortier,
où vous êtes par rapport à ça ?
-Je suis d'accord
avec cette idée
de bisexualité psychique
qui a été avancée
par des psychanalystes,
mais pas d'abord par Freud,
me semble-t-il.
Ca me semble important, en effet,
que cette idée
que ce qui a été dit avant,
qu'en fait, homme ou femme,
on a tous un corps
qui est potentiellement
complètement érogène,
et pas seulement
au niveau des organes sexuels,
sauf que les femmes ont été aussi
élevées dans ce rapport,
elles ont aussi un sexe
anatomique du côté
de la réceptivité,
mais qui peut être pris
aussi d'une autre façon.
C'est une question
de représentation.
Je pense qu'il y a une inhibition
du côté du masculin, inconsciente,
du fait de l'éducation,
à percevoir aussi son corps
comme potentiellement réceptif,
de même que la femme peut être
aussi complètement active.
Je pense que c'est plutôt
des inhibitions culturelles
et sociales
et que c'est un mythe
depuis l'Antiquité
de penser que les femmes
ont un superorgasme,
aussi tel que le disait Lacan,
absolument insatiable,
parce que ça participe
à l'idée que les femmes
sont plus sexuelles aussi
que les hommes,
ont une sorte d'insatiabilité,
de même que l'hystérie
renvoyait aussi
étymologiquement à ça,
au fait
qu'elles ont besoin d'avoir...
Qu'on leur remplisse
le ventre ou le sexe.
Donc, je pense
qu'il faut faire le tri
entre des représentations
psychanalytiques,
qui sont très pertinentes
pour envisager
ces processus sexuels,
qui sont avant tout
des processus
pas de pratiques,
mais qui sont avant tout
une psychosexualité,
c'est dans la tête,
et en même temps faire le tri
entre des représentations genrées
de l'orgasme féminin, etc.
Je pense qu'on a à peu près
le même orgasme,
ce sont des constructions sociales.
-Merci.
Alors, Lou Andreas-Salomé dit :
"Je ne peux conformer ma vie
à des modèles."
Alors, s'émanciper des modèles
peut conduire dans ce cas-là
à une pratique,
à une culture consumériste
de la sexualité.
"Jouir de son corps
"sans l'inscrire dans une relation
à l'être aimé",
je cite Roland Barthes,
est-ce que c'est toujours
de la sexualité,
Philippe Brenot ?
-Je trouve que votre question
permet d'élever
ce qu'on vient de dire,
parce que tout à l'heure,
j'ai eu l'impression,
en parlant de différences
homme-femme,
de ramener trop au génital.
C'est pas ça du tout,
la sexualité.
-Mais c'est aussi ça.
-Oui et non.
Chaque fois, en définitive,
la vraie dimension de la sexualité,
c'est lorsqu'on la transcende.
Il y a à la fois
bien sûr
ce qui se passe physiquement
dans cette excitation pulsionnelle,
dans la résolution des tensions,
mais la sexualité,
c'est la relation, je dirais,
à deux,
et je vais vous donner
une phrase amusante
que je dis souvent.
Il y a cette espèce d'idée
aujourd'hui,
vous évoquiez...
On parle trop des pratiques.
Les pratiques existent,
on peut les...
-Philippe Brenot,
permettez-moi
que vous précisiez quelque chose.
Vous dites
que la sexualité comme Barthes,
c'est la relation à deux.
Est-ce que la sexualité,
c'est la relation avec un jouet
ou par exemple
autre chose de virtuel ?
-Bien sûr.
-Donc, ce jouet,
ça devient un autre ?
-Très souvent,
dans mon "Eloge de la masturbation",
je le dis comme ça.
Il est très rare
qu'on ne fantasme pas
un partenaire potentiel,
une situation qu'on a vécue,
qui va souvent aider
au niveau fantasmatique,
mais pour revenir sur cette idée
des pratiques,
la sexualité, pour moi,
est beaucoup plus large
entre deux personnes,
quelle que soit l'orientation...
Très souvent,
vous avez cette histoire
des pratiques génitales,
on en a parlé, et on demande :
"Et les préliminaires ?"
Je dis, par exemple...
Lorsque je vois
un couple, je leur pose
une question directe,
je vous la pose
à tous les trois... quatre.
Quel temps doivent avoir
les préliminaires ?
Il y a des gens qui disent :
"Ca doit faire 30 minutes,
ça fait 10, ça fait..."
Je leur dis :
"Au moins huit jours."
Lorsque je dis cela,
pour leur faire comprendre...
C'est-à-dire que si,
pendant huit jours,
vous êtes dans une relation
où il y a les conditions de l'amour,
ça, ça vous regarde,
ça regarde l'un et l'autre
dans leur imaginaire,
leurs pratiques,
leur vécu, à ce moment-là,
peut-être qu'il peut se passer
quelque chose d'intime,
et sur plein de modèles,
il se passera
une chose.
-Vous croyez pas
qu'on est dans l'abstraction
par rapport aux téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent ?
Ils doivent se dire :
"La sexualité, c'est quasiment tout
sauf le rapport sexuel ?"
A vous écouter,
on dirait...
-A l'extrême, oui.
Vous avez raison.
-Vous diriez ça ?
-A l'extrême, oui.
Je trouve ça formidable,
lorsqu'on a pendant huit jours
une relation
qui est extraordinaire
ou qui plaît mutuellement,
peu importe le mode
de réalisation qu'il aura,
et à l'extrême, il peut
ne pas y avoir ni pénétration,
puisque c'est ce qui va poser
le plus de difficulté
aux uns et aux autres,
mais c'est pas pour l'éviter,
il peut y avoir des jouissances
de ce moment...
-Oui.
J'aimerais que chacun s'exprime,
parce que c'est
une question essentielle
pour les jeunes générations,
pour les seniors.
Pour vous, Marc Strauss,
il peut y avoir abstraction
de l'être aimé
sous forme d'un fantasme,
par exemple ?
-Il peut y avoir des sexualités
plus pulsionnelles,
étant entendu que "pulsionnel"
ne veut pas dire "animal"
ou "strictement génital",
c'est quand même lié
à des images,
à des empreintes
précoces de la vie.
Cela dit, là aussi,
pour prendre
une voie un peu différente,
je dirais que la sexualité,
c'est à trois.
C'est la relation de soi à soi
avec un ou des partenaires.
La relation de soi à soi,
car la relation de soi,
de ses propres représentations
de soi-même, avec sa jouissance,
est quelque chose
d'extraordinairement compliqué.
Là, il y a deux modes de bricolage,
il y a le bricolage
qu'évoque Lou Andreas,
c'est la dimension
transgressive,
effractive,
d'infraction de la sexualité,
qui est toujours présente,
d'une façon ou d'une autre,
il y a toujours quelque chose
aux limites de la loi,
de l'interdit.
Cette sexualité
est partagée par les hommes
et par les femmes,
qui est génitale,
et puis, il y a une sexualité
qui est autre,
qui est hors transgression
de la loi,
qui est dite sexualité féminine,
qui est un mode de jouissance
que vous contestez
peut-être.
-Je dis simplement
qu'elle peut être masculine.
-Oui, elle peut être masculine.
C'est plus difficile,
Lacan disant joliment
que l'homme
est "affligé de l'organe".
Donc, ça fait écran
pour lui à l'accès
à cette jouissance
que certaines femmes décrivent
et qui, en général,
disons-le quand même,
fout la trouille aux hommes
et aux femmes elles-mêmes.
Parce que, justement,
on peut pas la ranger
dans l'infraction,
on ne peut rien en dire.
-Justement, il n'a pas
que cet organe, l'homme,
il a tout son corps.
-Ca n'est pas lié à l'organe.
-Et même en ayant
et en utilisant cet organe,
il peut y avoir une circulation
de ce qui est considéré
comme masculin et féminin
au sein même du rapport sexuel.
-Bien sûr.
-Et entre activité
et réceptivité, sans qu'il y ait
toujours un clivage,
une séparation qui est souvent
frustrante pour l'un et l'autre.
-Qu'en pensez-vous,
Magali Croset-Calisto ?
-La première chose,
certains courants féministes
actuellement, je crois que c'est
Carla Lonzi,
qui essayent de réformer
la psychanalyse avec le phallus
par l'importance du clitoris,
comme clitoris en tant que phallus.
Et la visibilité
du clitoris aujourd'hui
permettrait
de repenser éventuellement
certaines constructions
psychanalytiques, clairement,
de l'accès à la sexualité.
Sinon, moi, ce que j'observe,
notamment en cabinet
de consultation
et dans toutes nos statistiques
actuelles,
c'est qu'il y a depuis quelques
années une dégénitalisation
des rapports.
-Mais est-ce que c'est un progrès ?
-Alors, ça pose...
-Toute évolution
n'est pas un progrès.
Pour qu'une innovation
soit innovation,
il faut qu'elle ait une adhésion
dans le temps long.
-On voit que la demande
de beaucoup de femmes
aujourd'hui,
la première demande en cabinet,
c'est pour une hypolibido,
une baisse de désir.
Quand on creuse un peu,
on leur pose des questions :
"quel est ce désir
"manquant,
de quoi vous n'avez pas envie ?",
on voit qu'il s'agit
souvent, in fine,
de la pénétration.
Si on donne
comme exercice sexologique,
on est dans du concret,
du pragmatique,
ce qu'on appelle
le sensate focus,
que Masters et Johnson
avaient lancé dans les années 60,
de dire : "Essayez des rapports
ensemble avec l'interdit
"de la pénétration",
le désir revient.
-Oui, mais...
Interdire la pénétration,
c'est mettre en cause
la reproduction.
-Elle est là,
la question.
-La reproduction doit
pouvoir exister aussi.
-Bien sûr,
mais il ne faut pas mélanger.
Est-ce qu'on parle...
-Vous pouvez pas non plus exclure
qu'il y a une jouissance
dans la pénétration.
-Beaucoup de femmes
éprouvent de la jouissance
pendant la pénétration, bien sûr,
simplement, beaucoup se sentent
être en devoir de répondre au désir
de leur partenaire
et à ce moment-là,
il y a un système
de demandes
et de réponses à donner.
Si une personne se sent
dans un devoir de réponse,
c'est un antilibido.
Donc, il faut casser ce système-là,
pouvoir s'extraire de ce système,
pour avoir des échanges de désir.
Et ça passe parfois
par le pas de côté
vis-à-vis de la pénétration
pendant quelque temps,
et des choses se libèrent
pour beaucoup de femmes.
-Une question précise.
Je voudrais...
On met en cause
les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui,
les jeunes, mais pas que,
passent un temps infini
devant des écrans,
les violences s'étalent.
Que pensez-vous
d'une cybersexualité,
c'est-à-dire faire l'amour
avec un écran ?
Est-ce que c'est une perversion
ou pas ?
-Alors...
L'écran est un médium,
ce n'est pas exactement
faire l'amour avec un écran.
Derrière, en général, il y a
soit une personne soit des images.
On voit qu'avec la pandémie,
cette cybersexualité s'est déployée,
soit parce que les couples
étaient à distance
et souhaitaient avoir
des rapports amoureux à distance.
Les personnes se retrouvant seules
se sont davantage inscrites
sur les réseaux de rencontres,
on a ça aussi,
et il y a donc une nouvelle
modélisation de la sexualité
qui en passe par l'écran.
Le cybersexe,
c'est comme "Le Moi cyborg",
dans notre société.
Il est en train
d'être étudié en France,
la France est à la pointe
de ça, avec notamment
Serge Tisseron, Frédéric Tordo.
Il y a des études concrètes.
On voit que le cybersexe
se passe dans un monde numérique,
il peut y avoir des endroits,
des sites spécifiques
où les personnes
vont via un avatar,
donc un "moi cyborg",
le moi, c'est une identité
numérique.
Et via cet avatar,
elles vont ressentir des choses
sans génitalisation.
Ca active le circuit de récompense,
il peut y avoir des orgasmes aussi
par écrans interposés,
évidemment.
-Philippe Brenot,
c'est charnel,
cette cybersexualité ?
-Forcément, puisque
ça se passe notamment
par notamment
cette réalisation orgastique.
C'est-à-dire qu'on est devant
quelque chose de compliqué
qui s'est passé avec, depuis 20 ans,
depuis les années 2000,
la multiplication
des images, des sites porno, OK ?
Il faut savoir,
l'un de mes étudiants
a fait un travail,
il y a quelques années,
en essayant de voir...
Le flux Internet du porno
est le premier consommateur,
devant les sites marchands,
dans le monde entier.
C'est-à-dire qu'en définitive,
il y a une utilisation,
en dehors
de nos pays occidentaux,
c'est pour certains
le seul moyen d'accès
des hommes,
en très grande majorité,
à une image d'excitation.
La majorité des hommes
en ont besoin.
Beaucoup de femmes sont plus
dans le monde fantasmatique
et peuvent y arriver facilement.
A partir de là,
il y a quelque chose
de compliqué,
qui est une dépendance
à ce mode d'excitation...
-Mais alors, Philippe Brenot,
je vous interroge.
Vous dites cette chose-là,
mais quand on voit
les sites de rencontres,
les sites sexuels,
on vous envoie des mails sans arrêt,
"vous pouvez avoir
la plus belle fille du monde",
ils sont tous basés
sur la relation sexuelle,
ils sont pas basés sur des orgasmes
qui pourraient se produire
de la plante du pied
jusqu'aux cheveux.
Comment vous expliquez
cette chose-là ?
-C'est très vrai qu'aujourd'hui,
quand même,
il est difficile pour la plupart
des gens d'imaginer un couple
qui n'ait pas une réalisation
sexuelle épanouie.
C'est les images de la société
qui ont changé.
Moi, je conseille beaucoup,
que ce soit à travers les sites,
que ce soit par l'utilisation
du porno,
que ce soit fait de façon soft,
ça peut se faire de temps en temps.
Sinon, c'est vrai que l'addiction
va amener
quelque chose de compliqué
avec soi et ensuite,
dans la relation avec les autres.
Mais comme intermédiaire,
les relations dans la société,
par exemple pour se rencontrer,
puisqu'on a
des tranches de vie,
il va y avoir des rencontres
au fil de la vie,
c'est pas très facile,
les sites peuvent y aider,
très bien,
mais conseil aux auditeurs :
vous faites très courtement
des contacts, des chats.
Très vite, vous passez au téléphone,
vous vous rencontrez et vous voyez.
Mais passer du temps là-dessus,
on est devant des choses
qui sont compliquées.
On a vu combien de fois
des couples qui, ensuite,
n'arrivent plus à se séparer
et sont très mal ensemble ?
-Alors,
cybersexualité,
qu'en pensez-vous, Marc Strauss ?
-C'est des faciliteurs
de la masturbation
et la masturbation
ne date pas d'hier.
Alors, effectivement,
il y avait les gravures grivoises,
quelqu'un a dit :
"La deuxième photo faite au monde
"a dû être une photo
pornographique."
C'est assez astucieux,
je trouve,
je sais pas si c'est vrai.
Maintenant, c'est à portée de main,
si je puis dire.
C'est la mise en scène
des fantasmes,
c'est sûr que d'être confronté
à une scène sexuelle
est en soi transgressif,
et donc excitant, et ensuite,
on a le catalogue des choix
préférentiels, jusqu'au moment
où ça s'épuise, évidemment.
Là aussi, la sexualité libérée,
sans entraves,
sans la dimension transgressive,
ça finit par produire de l'ennui.
Ou alors, une forme d'addiction qui,
effectivement,
coupe la recherche
du lien à l'autre.
Mais c'est une autre affaire,
la sexualité avec un partenaire
ne se limite pas
à la masturbation, pas du tout.
Et on voit bien, quand même,
les jeunes dont on parle comme ça,
il y a quand même une chose
qui les préoccupe beaucoup,
c'est l'amour,
ils continuent à chercher,
à vouloir l'amour et la fidélité.
La prolifération du porno
n'y change rien.
-On va maintenant parler
de certaines déviations,
parce qu'il y a eu de nombreux
ouvrages, je pense à ceux
de Camille Kouchner,
de Vanessa Springora,
maintenant, un ouvrage
d'Hélène Devynck, "Impunité".
Elle dénonce
le comportement
d'un homme célèbre,
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor, et qui,
en vertu des dispositions
du code de procédure pénal,
bénéficie
de la présomption d'innocence.
Cela dit, ce qui est en cause,
et ça rejoint notre débat,
c'est le sentiment
de toute-puissance,
le rapport d'ultra domination
de celui qui s'arroge le pouvoir
pour imposer un rapport sexuel.
Pensez-vous souhaitable
et réalisable
que la justice
soit plus prompte à condamner
tous les prédateurs sexuels
quelle que soit leur notoriété ?
Qu'en pensez-vous ?
Corinne Fortier.
-Mais certainement.
Enfin, ça me semble
complètement évident,
et la France est en retard
par rapport
à énormément d'autres pays,
en particulier d'Europe du nord,
je pense à la Suède,
où ces comportements
sont habituels encore aujourd'hui
dans toutes les sphères du pouvoir,
que ce soit intellectuel,
artistique, cinématographique,
scientifique, hospitalier, etc.
En fait,
ce sont des abus de pouvoir
qui participent du patriarcat.
Souvent, les pédophiles
peuvent avoir des pratiques
avec des garçons et des filles,
parce que ces enfants,
qui sont avant l'adolescence,
ne sont quasiment pas sexués,
pour eux.
Ce sont presque des anges.
Non, mais c'est vrai.
La question de l'adolescence
et de la puberté
donne une sexuation,
elle rend masculin et féminin.
Vous voyez souvent des pédophiles,
je pense à ceux de l'Eglise,
ils abusent aussi bien
des petits garçons
que des petites filles
indistinctement.
Donc, c'est quelque chose...
Etant donné
les traumas que ça laisse
derrière soi, la difficulté à avoir
une sexualité après dans sa vie,
la difficulté à être en couple,
des traumatismes
qui restent à vie,
bien sûr qu'ils doivent
être condamnés, et souvent,
ils ne le sont pas.
-Donc, vous êtes favorable...
-Ils reproduisent...
Bien sûr, ça me semble
complètement évident.
La France est très, très en retard.
-Je voudrais prolonger
cette discussion
en disant que ceux qui utilisent
la toute-puissance
pour avoir des rapports
ou des supposés rapports sexuels,
est-ce que ça a à voir,
quelque part,
avec une pulsion de mort ?
-Ah...
-Utiliser cette chose-là...
-C'est en tout cas,
effectivement...
Entendons-nous.
Ces prédateurs,
je suis d'accord avec votre terme,
dans la mesure où il y a
la dimension pulsionnelle.
Précisons, "pulsionnelle"
veut dire "fantasmatique".
C'est déjà une construction
bricolée, une image.
Par exemple, le journaliste célèbre
dont vous parlez,
il y a un côté
assez misérable
dans les témoignages
qui viennent de tous les côtés,
l'image que ça évoque,
pour moi, strictement pour moi,
c'est celle du village,
du coq du village d'antan
sur son tas de fumier
qui de temps en temps
saute sur une poule.
Je vous assure, j'ai vu
des patients qui ont été élevés
à la campagne et pour lesquels
cette image du coq du village
a une dimension prégnante
dans leur vie d'adulte.
Il y a un côté pathétique,
à la fois prédateur,
mais pathétique,
car il y a l'ignorance
du consentement de l'autre,
de l'autre comme sujet
capable de dire quelque chose.
Alors que dans les histoires,
il faut les différencier,
l'histoire de Duhamel.
Duhamel s'est pas tapé
tous les petits garçons du village,
Et Camille Kouchner raconte bien
comment, à Sanary,
tout le monde était heureux
et c'était un endroit merveilleux,
et c'est un homme qui avait tout,
il avait tout, le pouvoir,
l'argent, l'accès aux femmes.
Il a été obligé de s'inventer
une saloperie quand même,
pour arriver à bander,
ce qui montre, si vous permettez,
ce qui illustre une remarque
de Lacan qui dit que les riches
ont beaucoup de mal à bander.
Pour finir, quand même,
pour finir sur Matzneff,
Matzneff, pédophilie,
prédateur certainement,
puisqu'il prend les enfants
comme des objets de son fantasme,
il se préoccupe pas de savoir
si ça leur fait du mal,
mais c'est pas de chance
pour lui, c'est pas
de chance pour un homme,
ça arrive aux hommes,
d'avoir un fantasme
unique et prévalent
qui leur est nécessaire
pour l'exercice de leur sexualité.
-Tout à fait.
Je voudrais devant
cette citation célèbre
savoir si vous pensez,
Philippe Brenot
et Magali Croset-Calisto,
que les violeurs
sont des mâles
qui ont du mal à bander.
-D'abord, dans l'absolu,
les violeurs sont pas que des mâles,
il y a
une très grande majorité de...
-En général.
Est-ce que vous diriez,
vous reprenez cette idée
qu'ils violent
car leur sexualité est misérable
et qu'ils ont du mal à bander ?
-Mais je dirais "misérable",
car il y a un misérabilisme...
Je ne veux pas les exonérer
de quoi que ce soit.
Vous comprenez,
c'est inimaginable, inacceptable.
Et le problème,
on a beaucoup parlé
de consentement,
c'est pas acceptable
que ça se poursuive,
c'est pas acceptable non plus
qu'il y ait prescription.
La grande difficulté...
Je vous ai dit tout à l'heure,
j'avais écrit un article,
parce qu'en tant
qu'anthropologue physique,
j'aime travailler
avec des chimpanzés, gorilles,
il n'y a pas d'inceste
chez les grands primates
pour une raison très simple.
A la puberté, les femelles
vont vivre dans un autre groupe.
Qui a inventé ça ?
Elle ne rencontrera jamais
le père ou les frères.
Il se trouve que l'humanité,
alors qu'il y a ce que
les zoologues appellent
l'évitement de l'inceste,
qui existe aussi chez les félins,
enfin, peu importe,
en passant à l'humanité,
la fragilité de la transmission,
ça a été le langage.
Depuis notre enfance,
on a entendu des interdits.
Traditionnellement,
ça se disait beaucoup plus.
Le problème aujourd'hui
de la prescription,
ça se heurte à quelque chose
d'important dans nos sociétés,
c'est que la société
peut être rédemptrice,
mais là, on peut s'interroger.
L'artifice que j'avais trouvé,
c'était que c'était comme
le crime contre l'humanité,
qui est la seule raison
d'imprescriptibilité,
c'est qu'en fait, on touchait
à l'humanité de l'enfant
en train de se construire.
-Il nous reste
très peu de temps.
Magali Croset-Calisto,
dans votre cabinet de sexologue,
vous entendez ce genre de remarque,
"les riches ont du mal à bander,
"c'est pour cela
qu'il y a des viols" ?
-Je les entends pas forcément.
-Vous l'entendez, vous ?
-Ca pose une question,
c'est faire fi aussi
de tous les adjuvants
à la sexualité,
notamment médicamenteux.
Maintenant, la question
se pose beaucoup moins,
puisque les hommes peuvent
avoir recours facilement,
à partir d'une ordonnance,
aux adjuvants sexuels,
donc pour être en érection.
Donc, déjà,
ça tient moins.
Et puis, moi, j'aimerais revenir
sur ce qu'a dit Philippe Brenot,
je pense aussi vraiment
que la prescription
dans notre société est quelque chose
qui ne permet pas
la parole des êtres
qui ont été agressés.
Aujourd'hui, elle a été reculée
un petit peu,
je crois que c'est 30 ans
à partir de 18 ans.
Mais il n'empêche,
c'est aussi faire fi
de tout ce mécanisme
de sidération...
-Quelqu'un qui a fauté enfant
doit être condamné
au quatrième âge ?
-Oui.
-Il doit faire face à ses actes,
il y a une loi dans notre pays.
Face à certains types
de comportement comme la prédation,
c'est le rappel à la loi
et uniquement le rappel à la loi
qui permet
une prise de conscience pour eux,
car ça les protège aussi eux-mêmes.
Donc oui, c'est important.
-Vous êtes d'accord,
Corinne Fortier ?
-Tout à fait.
Après, il y a aussi
des systèmes hormonaux
qui permettent
de bloquer l'érection de ces hommes
et leurs pulsions.
-Mais comment les reconnaître ?
-Justement...
-Comment voulez-vous ?
-Justement,
ils doivent être accusés.
Pour cela,
il faut cette libération
qui a commencé avec MeToo,
mais qui est balbutiante.
Je dirais pas qu'on est libérées,
que les femmes...
On le voit, d'ailleurs.
Ces hommes sont toujours protégés.
Il faut voir aussi comment
la médiatisation de Strauss-Kahn
lorsqu'il a eu ce...
il a abusé
cette femme dans un hôtel
aux Etats-Unis, on disait :
"C'est un grand homme,
il n'a pas fait ça."
Tout de suite,
on est dans des logiques
de réseau, souvent aussi
masculinistes, mais pas que,
de protection
d'un pouvoir, où la parole
des femmes est écrasée
ou où elles vont être diabolisées.
On va dire :
"Elle l'a cherché,
"elle est rentrée dans sa chambre,
elle avait une jupe..."
Donc, souvent, les femmes,
encore aujourd'hui, on sait que...
-On va terminer là-dessus
en un mot.
Si le consentement,
finalement, dans une relation,
n'est qu'une présomption
de consentement, finalement,
que valent les mots
dans ce cas-là ?
Qu'en pensez-vous, Marc Strauss ?
On a peu de temps
pour conclure là-dessus.
-Je pense que...
Evidemment, la prise en compte
du consentement
du ou de la partenaire
est fondamentale, ça va de soi.
L'autre est aussi un sujet,
mais encore une fois,
l'autre n'est pas dans la sexualité,
l'autre n'est pas qu'un sujet.
Il y a là les zones grises
du consentement,
l'appareillage discursif,
la soumission des femmes,
le fait qu'on dit oui
pour faire plaisir
parce qu'on ne peut pas dire non.
Il y a une zone très grise.
-Parfois, on dit pas oui non plus.
-Il y a une zone
qui n'est pas grise,
c'est effectivement la perversion
où l'autre est pris comme objet.
-Autrement dit,
céder n'est pas consentir,
reste à savoir...
-Cela dit,
pour Matzneff, Springora,
il y avait
une histoire d'amour entre eux.
-Ce qui complique encore
les choses.
-Ca a craqué
quand elle s'est aperçue
qu'elle n'était qu'objet
du fait de sa jeunesse
et pas aimée
comme elle le pensait.
-Bien.
On va terminer,
si vous voulez, là-dessus.
Je vais vous présenter
une bibliographie.
Magali Croset-Calisto,
vous avez publié
récemment,
enfin, presque récemment,
ça date de quelques mois,
"Les révolutions de l'orgasme".
Magali Croset-Calisto,
peut-on dire que ce livre
permet aux gens de voir
l'étendue ubiquitaire de l'orgasme ?
Vous accepteriez ça ?
-J'espère.
On parlait de l'éventail du sexe,
donc là, c'est l'éventail
de l'orgasme, j'espère.
-Hélène Devynck, dont j'ai cité
l'ouvrage, "Impunité",
qui est sorti au Seuil.
Je voudrais également signaler
que Magali Croset-Calisto
a mis en ligne un podcast
qui s'appelle naturellement
"Orgasmia :
"Les coulisses de la jouissance".
Je voudrais signaler
cette revue,
"Psychanalyse Yetu",
dans laquelle il y a un intérêt
pour ce domaine
de l'éventail du sexe
et à laquelle a contribué
Corinne Fortier,
dont je signale qu'elle a publié
un ouvrage qui s'appelle
"Le corps de l'identité",
publié chez Karthala.
Je voudrais également
signaler deux ouvrages
du Dr Philippe Brenot,
à la fois
"Pourquoi c'est si compliqué
l'amour ?,
mais aussi une BD
sur l'incroyable histoire du sexe,
tous les deux publiés aux Arènes.
C'est une BD extrêmement réussie
et je voudrais signaler,
de Marc Strauss,
"La presse du temps",
aux éditions Nouvelles
du Champ lacanien.
"La presse du temps",
c'est quoi ?
-"La presse du temps",
c'est ça.
C'est que dans la constitution
subjective,
le temps tient
une place fondamentale.
C'est une thèse de Lacan,
il a écrit un article
en 45 là-dessus, qui est
le fondement de son oeuvre,
et c'est un commentaire
de cet article,
essentiellement, pas uniquement.
Il est question
de la genèse homosexuelle.
Mais je...
On est assez loin de la sexualité.
-Merci, mesdames,
messieurs,
d'avoir participé à cette émission.
Merci à l'équipe de LCP
qui va la réaliser,
et je voudrais
avant de vous quitter
vous soumettre cette citation.
"La sexuation est une décision
"s'inscrivant dans une filiation
"qui respecte l'altérité
"comme fondement du couple.
Sans cette altérité,
"le sexe est hors lieu."
C'est une citation
de Pierre Bruno.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA